ah
y leyes significa nuestra casa en lengua
yoruba y es una con música lo blocó como
nos llaman en brasil que revolucionó al
carnaval nació en 1974 en la ciudad de
salvador de bahía y desde entonces sólo
ha tenido integrantes negros un ensamble
que utiliza voces instrumentos y bailes
para combatir el racismo o las
desigualdades y promover la educación
dentro de las comunidades upfront con
motivo de festival petronio álvarez en
colombia el mayor festival de cultura
afro de américa latina hablamos con
antonio carlos dos santos el presidente
y fundador de este grupo histórico
y le añadí muchas gracias por compartir
este momento con nosotros en france 24
sub loco nació durante la dictadura
militar en brasil surgió como un
movimiento de resistencia
esta misma esa misma esencia política
está siempre en la raíz de los blocos en
brasil
d
hoy existen otros blocos afro en brasil
y en el mundo
por ejemplo el segundo block o afro fue
en menudo banzo creado en el año 1976
pero los nuevos blocos afro en el
salvador de bahía no consiguieron
mantener esta resistencia de ser
organizaciones exclusivas de negros
los otros locos se rindieron apenas
comenzaron
porque no tuvieron la resistencia que
tuvimos nosotros y la preocupación de
las personas negras
en esa época nadie quería asumir su
negritud
la gente decía son morenos son que
malditos y nosotros insistimos en eso
entonces y le apuesta todo a que solo
puede ser dirigido por negros
es un bloco que sólo puede ser compuesto
por integrantes negros pero los otros
blancos se rindieron bueno no es que se
rindieron sino que no consiguieron tener
esa búsqueda que nosotros hicimos por
nuestra propia resistencia y entonces
las personas valoran eso y eso nos
fortaleció mucho
ustedes son entonces el primer bloco
afro de brasil y hoy nos encontramos en
el festival de música del petronio aquí
en colombia
para que piensen ustedes de tocar aquí
en cali para este festival afro en
colombia
estamos muy felices tocamos para mucha
gente
estuvimos recientemente en parís en
junio
ayer participamos en un evento masivo en
río de janeiro
nosotros ya recorrimos medio mundo y por
eso estamos muy felices
pero muy felices porque hoy existe la
llamada cultura del tambor esa
transformación que hicimos en los blocos
a frank desde hoy de música al fascismo
de fas de cumplir
porque antes sólo se hablaba en las
escuelas de samba de río de janeiro las
mulatas no sé qué
y nosotros cambiamos eso porque nosotros
asumimos nuestra negritud como muy feliz
vivir entonces estamos muy felices de
llegar a un show en parís y ver muchas
personas no negras tocando la percusión
del bloque afro
[Música]
es muy impactante pero hay que hacer
mucho más
no puedes exótica pero no se puede
quedar sólo en una cosa esporádica así
que estamos muy felices de estar en un
festival como éste de música y de
cultura negra
sobre la relación entre colombia y
brasil yo
[Música]
y que son países del mismo continente
países vecinos
estos puentes entre los dos países están
creciendo en los últimos años
que quieren lograr ustedes con esta
hermandad nada
y ya tenemos la relación más fuerte
dentro del mercosur
porque somos vecinos pero y le hay puede
también dar una contribución muy grande
para este acercamiento
puedo decir aquí de primera mano estoy
pensando y voy a empezar a hablar con
personas de la dirección del festival de
petróleo
para que en 2024 hagamos algo juntos
para el carnaval porque las personas
necesitan conocer mejor a colombia y no
pensar que aquí sólo hay narcotráfico
drogas entonces esperamos que para 2024
podamos traer y llevar de aquí para allá
estas manifestaciones artísticas hasta
brasil especialmente a salvador
y además de tocar música ustedes tienen
muchos proyectos de educación que giran
en torno a suerte nos podría hablar un
poquito sobre eso nos falta sobre eso
en
1988 fundamos una escuela de música
luego una asociación y después con la
creación y la inauguración de la sede se
amplió empezamos a hacer cursos de
fabricación de instrumentos de ayudantes
de cocina informática electricidad y fue
una ampliación total
[Música]
pero a pesar de hacer filantropía que
sea todo gratuito hay que tener un
paraguas porque no tenemos una cultura
de voluntariado entonces tenemos que
estar comprometidos con las personas con
sus transportes sus salarios y si no
tenemos esa complicidad con el gobierno
con la prefectura con el sector privado
ahí es realmente complicado
y hemos tenido varias asociaciones en
salvados pero necesitamos más como dice
la canción quiero mucho más que deporte
y carnaval
[Música]